uh hey my name is ben johnson
um i'm talking about raft today we're
talking about extruded consensus
i wrote a library for this protocol back
in april called go raft
that's kind of what i'm talking about
today
so you know whenever i talk about
distributed consensus
which isn't like a common topic really
to bring up but people always wonder
what
distributed consensus actually is
so it's pretty simple when you break it
down distributed just means you have a
bunch of nodes
and then you know consensus just means
you're coming to an agreement so you
have a single value or like a system
state
that you're trying to come to an
agreement on
so you know when we talk about this a
lot of times it's used in uh databases
like master slave replication um
you can have leader election so if you
have one leader you need to choose
out of a group that's another instance
and then also distributed locks so if
you're talking about you know you have a
bunch of nodes that all want to
share one resource you just need to
share it one at a time
you can use this type of system for it
so if you're talking about like actual
distributed consensus protocols
that are used in you know like popular
ones it's really short history like
there's basically one and it's paxos
but everyone talks about uh this
viewstamp replication which is similar
to raft
but it's uh it's not widely used
another one zab which is used in
zookeeper but it's just pretty much used
in zookeeper
so paxus was uh was written back in or
you know made back in 89 by lizzie
lanport
and uh oh so and you know i'll give you
that kind of
brief rundown of paxo so you have five
different roles within paxos
you have a client which is kind of
requesting a change to the system
and that goes to the proposer and the
proposer kind of that advocates for the
client
and then the proposer then kind of talks
to this this group of acceptors and if
you can get a quorum or like a
majority of them they can connect with
then it comes back and says okay i'm
ready for all that
and the proposer goes and sends the
change over once it's accepted
it's kind of a learned value that's the
new value of the system and it goes into
all these learners
and now the proposer becomes the leader
and that's kind of in a nutshell what
paxos is
so if this seems kind of confusing to
you um i share the same
uh you know understanding of it it's
kind of confusing it's kind of opaque
there's a lot of roles sometimes they
get collapsed down to
you know different roles are shared and
different versions of paxos
but that's the basic idea
and then every time you have a new
change we need to go through this whole
whole dance if you guys have any
questions just
raise a hand or shout out
okay so now that we're talking about
paxos you know this isn't about paxils
let's get into actual raft uh details
so it's created by this hipster looking
guy right here
uh diego angaro he's a phd student over
at stanford
uh and then also this less hipster
looking guy john osterhout
who's a professor over there it came out
in about april
april may but this year so
the reference implementation is called
log cabin it's used in this
project called ram cloud and this is why
i love the internet
like you can search for raft log cabin
and there's actually an image result
so it got really popular really fast i
don't know if it was just the right time
for this kind of library but or this
kind of protocol there's actually 28
implementations across different
languages there's like eight
go implementations um
i know there's um there's one from f
sharp this guy here
hendrick was over there uh two of the
guys from braintree also did
go ones ben mills i forget the other guy
but
um i'm just curious does anybody else
have a raft implementation
in this room okay so if you guys have
questions go and uh
talk to those guys as well afterwards it
yeah just kind of got to be really uh
popular
it's also in commercial use so it's not
just theoretical at this point
uh there's a company called core os it's
a y combinator company
they actually made a tool called scd to
kind of share a configuration
across all your your nodes in your
cluster uh and it's backed by go raft
and they did a lot of work to help out
with that library as well
and they also did the the cool little
design there with the the gopher
and the raft
okay so i'm actually talking about raft
itself
uh so paxos is actually based on this
theoretical
like this greek island that has this
parliamentary system
and how people vote and how that
knowledge kind of gets transferred out
so there's also kind of a when i think
about raft i think of uh
a democratically elected dictatorship so
that's kind of
the sense of government you can kind of
think about so you have three different
roles in raft
you have the leader which this is a
little aside if you're ever looking up
democratically elected dictatorships
you get basically like mussolini and
hitler and you don't want to put hitler
on a slide up there so
that is mussolini
you have the follower right here and
they just they take whatever
you know the leader tells them and just
keeps doing it
then you have a candidate so if the
followers don't actually have a leader
to go off of
they don't hear from him they you know
they can become candidates and then
eventually leaders themselves
okay so this is going to be the quick
rundown before we get into details
but this is just the high level have a
high level overview
so let's say we have three nodes under
cluster they all start as uh
as followers here so if if they don't
hear anything from a leader
one of them is going to flip over into a
candidate
and this starts what's called an
election so this uh this candidate right
here is gonna start asking for votes
so you know ask for votes from the
followers you know they they haven't
voted for anybody so they'll come back
and say okay
so now it has enough votes to then
become the leader so
at this point start sending kind of
these commands for how to change the
state of the system
from the leader down to the follower so
that they all can
have the same state they just keep
replicating these kind of iterative
commands
through log entries uh if there's no
actual changes to the state
uh the leader just kind of keeps its
oppressive rain by
just sending these heartbeats and
basically saying to the followers you
know
i'm still here i'm still here don't try
to elect a new leader
okay so in the case that a leader dies
or the
the network goes down or whatnot you
know the the followers will just not
hear anything for a little bit
so one's going to change into a a
candidate
he'll ask for a vote and in this
three-node cluster uh you just need a
majority to win the actual leader
uh leadership so it has two votes one
for itself one from the follower
and then it becomes a leader so now
we'll start setting down these log
entries and heartbeats
and uh this process just keeps going
over and over again as
nodes die and come back you'll also
notice too
you always need a majority of nodes
running to actually make your cluster
live and actually work so if you have
three nodes
and two go down you're down if you have
five nodes two go down
or three go down then you're down so
that's
that's when i trade off with uh these
kind of quorum based and majority
uh systems uh so let's
there's really two pieces to raft so you
have leader election on one side you
know how do you actually figure out
who's going to make changes to the
system and then you have log replication
that's the other kind of the other half
so yeah in this leader election we're go
you know let's kind of step by step
look through how this works out uh and
at the bottom you can kind of see a
timeline
the whole thing is one second we're just
going to use kind of a fraction of that
and then on the top here we have three
nodes
and the ones on there so the f means
follower the one is the term the current
election term
so these terms they just they keep going
and the leader will just
stay in a term for as long as it can and
if it kind of uh if it gets deposed or
you know if it dies or whatnot a new one
will be
uh be elected in a new term so they're
all in term one right now okay
so they're all wait around for the
election timeout
so basically the length of time that it
takes you know they haven't heard
anything from a leader
um and it's randomized it's between 150
milliseconds so 300 milliseconds
and then one of them is going to flip
over hopefully just one of them you
can't get more but in this case we're
just talking about
the happy path uh one's gonna flip over
to our candidate
and it's gonna increment its uh election
term to term two so it's gonna start
requesting votes
and uh let's say in this instance it
hits one of them but for some reason the
the request down to the bottom one
doesn't work out uh you know the first
one's gonna grant
so now it has two votes one from itself
one from a follower and it becomes
leader of term two and starts kind of
blasting out saying
i'm the leader and then everybody that
hears that will start following
and that then everyone actually anytime
you actually see a term
uh and like a node sees a term a new
term a higher term
it'll just move up to that term so if
you're sending log entries or
uh vote requests or whatnot they'll
always use the last term itself
oh also if you're looking at at the
bottom it really doesn't take long once
the timeout goes it only takes
you know depending on your network i
mean this stuff goes pretty fast to kind
of resolve who the leader is
uh okay so that was leader election any
questions so far
uh so that's leader election kind of
best case scenario one candidate flips
over
and you're good uh another thing that
can happen is you can actually get a
split vote where you have two candidates
that come up at the same time
they both start grabbing votes and then
neither one gets a majority
so in this case you know we'll wait for
the timeout they both flip over
and now we have two candidates in term
two trying to get votes
so let's say they first go and get these
first two uh
followers they get votes from them
because they haven't voted for anyone
yet
uh next they'll kind of cross over and
try to get the other ones
but these guys have already voted in
term two so they can't vote again
so it's gonna get denied they try to get
votes from each other
that doesn't work out either and then
we're in this kind of stalemate where
you know no more votes can be had they
each have two votes
and it's not a majority yet you need
three votes in this four four cluster
system or four node system so we're
going to keep waiting
and then eventually it's going to change
over to the next uh next term
so now the election term is term three
and then this term
is going to start getting votes from
that first candidate so hopefully that
one flips over before the next one with
the
randomized timeout so it's going to grab
votes
i can get votes for both of them in term
three because they've been voted in term
three
and now it's the leader because it has
three votes
this one might then not recognize that
that one's a leader yet
and then try to get votes it'll get
denied at that point
and once the leader actually starts
shooting out saying hey
i'm leader of term three that other
candidate is going to
step down and then at this point you
kind of have a stable system where we
have a leader
and a whole bunch of followers that's
kind of what we want okay
that makes sense
yeah yeah i mean it's set at about 150
milliseconds so 300
is the range you can adjust that if you
want to if you definitely have like a
much longer latency but that's the idea
yeah
exactly yep go ahead back there
they're all related in the sense that
they more or less act independently
unless they hear from a leader in which
case they just kind of
you know they'll just keep following
whatever leader they have until there is
that time out if they don't hear
anything from anyone
and at that point they'll kind of become
a candidate
and then hopefully a leader so they're
they're fairly isolated and independent
until
they need to kind of step up any other
questions
oh yeah so the leader there is now
three say that the leader is still
healthy would i have a term for when the
leader shoots again
like that the fact that he's still a
leader uh you won't have a term for
until
one of these followers gets cut off and
then he's uh
kind of elected elected itself as a
leader at that point
uh that is a really good question
there's there's a slider we'll
show on that a bit it'll basically it'll
start incrementing that um
that candidate on that on the split but
if you have a split
you can only have either it's going to
be split you know say it right down the
middle
and you have two and neither one's going
to have a majority of the nodes so
neither one's going to be functional
um they'll just kind of keep increasing
their terms until they connect back
together
and then one will become a leader um
or the other cases where you just get
one cut off from the other three and
those other three are can have a
majority
between them and they'll keep
functioning but that one that's isolated
is just going to be down right how does
it know when to switch
to the next so the terms is going to be
whenever the the follower
doesn't hear from a leader it's going to
automatically flip over
to become a candidate after a certain
time or a timeout and then it just
increments by 1.
does that mean it clocks off to be a
singer no there's no clocks
to worry about in this uh yeah
how do they know about each other is
just broadcasting on the local subnet or
do you have to
tell them these are all the machines
involved with this wrap
uh you have to tell them what the
cluster configuration is
you'll have to know explicitly how to
get to them and that you know ip address
or whatnot
as well as you have to know the total
account so you can calculate the quorum
size or the majority
anywhere yeah if the substantive notes
get
isolated so that their idea of the
term number is not increasing and in the
meantime
no what will actually happen is that
it'll try to elect
um itself and then there's actually a
replicated log
that we're going to get to in a second
so that log is going to basically have
kind of the current state and all the
commands
to get to that state so if it realizes
it doesn't have the current log it's
going to try to become
a candidate it'll see that it doesn't
have the current log
and step down although its term number
will now be visible to the leader and
the leader will
actually update its term to be higher
than that that
candidate was trying to be does that
make sense or re-elect a new candidate i
think so
okay yeah
okay yeah any other questions oh yeah
well so if a note if a node receives a
message from a leader
from another node saying i am a leader
does it unquestionably
accept that that node is a leader only
if it's at a higher term so if it's a
lower term
the lower one will be deposed will step
down
to a follower so whichever one has a
higher term basically
for the same term for two different
nodes
then you're broken yeah they won't work
i mean
yeah under the rules of the system that
shouldn't occur but
because you can only get a uh you can
only become leader if you get a majority
of votes for the term
guarantee that that could never happen
we're trying to guarantee that that
could never
yeah i mean under the you can only vote
once per term
and you can only become a leader for a
given term if you get a majority of
votes and since you can only get
a majority one time within the cluster
it should ensure that
you only get one uh one liter per term
yep
uh i mean you can yeah under the system
you don't have um
like the byzantine problem where you
actually have you know corrupted
messages or things like that
you're assuming that everyone's kind of
working together for the common goal
there's no like uh
nefarious nodes out there any
any other questions
so so that's leader election that's kind
of the best or good case scenario
bad case scenario but all resolves to a
single leader that's kind of what you
want
so the other half is log replication uh
in this case so we have three nodes here
we have a leader
sorry i wave my hands a lot and that
actually doesn't have anything to do
with what's going on
on there sometimes so just ignore me uh
so what happens
is that you know we'll have a leader
already elected we'll assume and then we
have these two followers
so the state of the system is actually
replicated by this log
and each one has their own individual
log
so what's going to happen you know we'll
there's a also there's a heartbeat
that occurs in here so uh that that
leader is gonna keep sending out these
messages
either passing along new entries in this
log to the
followers or it'll basically tell them
that i don't have any more entries but
i'm
still here so a new kind of uh entry in
here oh
also we're also tracking this is
basically just single string values on
each node
so this is the most simple database you
can think of
but it's each one's going to have its
own string they're all initialized to
blank strings right now
so the the first entry in here in this
log is gonna be sally
so sally comes in it's written to the
log but that value
doesn't show anywhere yet you know
outside of this this log
it just lives on the leader right now
what's going to happen is that
it's going to send this rpc called
append entries out to the
the followers and then the followers
will actually write that to their log
and then come back and confirm so say
this this one follower comes back first
it says okay i already have this written
as long as it's written on a majority of
nodes
then um then the that entry can be
committed on the the leader itself
so now it's committed on the leader and
the leader sees this as sally at that
point
and then you know you can get that other
confirmation back from the other node
although at this point it's already
committed at the top and
in the leader so it doesn't really
matter and at this point when it sends
out the next heartbeat it'll basically
say
i don't have any more entries for you
but that other entry that i sent you
it's committed now so you guys go ahead
and commit it
so at this point everything is committed
okay so we're all sally
okay and then you know
we can get another heartbeat there's no
newer information so just kind of keeps
sending out that heartbeat
and at this point you know just before
the next heartbeat we get a
an entry called bob so now we want to
change the system from sally to bob
uh so it's going to send out these
append entries everyone's gonna get bob
i'm gonna come back and confirm it's
committed now
and the next heartbeat it's gonna commit
to everywhere so now everybody's bob
okay does that make sense okay
so that's the best case scenario with
everything you know all the nodes are up
network's up you're doing great so most
of the time this is how it should really
work it's just
you're starting out these these entries
it's kind of a two-space commit
sort of a protocol so now we're going to
talk about network partitions
i don't know kyle's having to talk about
this kyle kingsbury uh in the big room
after lunch i should check it out if you
for interested in this stuff
but in the case of network partitions
you really want to make sure
that you don't have this idea of a split
brain where you have two leaders that
can both commit
and change this log in the state of the
system at the same time because
once that partition comes back up or you
know resolved itself
then all these nodes are going to try to
talk to each other and you have to
resolve what those
conflicts are and you don't want that
now there are you can do stuff with
vector clocks if you want to talk to the
basho guys
tom santero's over there i'm sorry yeah
there's all kinds of actual people
they'll tell you about dr klox
um so you know we'll do the same thing
we'll put sally in here
sends out comes back and commits it
you know sends out the heartbeat so
everyone's committed we're all sally
okay
now we get this the dreaded network
partition in here so some of the nodes
are cut off
it's not like they're down but they're
just cut off so now we have these two
separate
clusters essentially that you know it's
one cluster but it's separated these
little subclusters
so now what we want to do you know it's
still sending out the heartbeats on the
top from the leader
it still thinks it's the leader it's
going to keep trying to be the leader
we put in a new value of bob it gets
replicated over to the follower
comes back and confirms but at this
point we don't actually have a majority
so they can't be committed we're still
waiting for at least one other node in
our five node cluster
uh to actually make this a committed
value so it's just going to hang out
and we're kind of in this limbo state at
this point so
after the timeout occurs down at the
bottom you know one of these nodes is
going to flip over to be a
uh candidate and term two so you know
let's try to get some votes
there's three nodes down there so i can
actually grab all the votes and
become a leader and at this point we
have two leaders which sounds like a
really bad thing
but we're isolated on top and that we
can't commit values
because we don't have a majority so now
our functioning cluster is really on the
bottom here
with uh the leader two in the second
term
so we're going to put in a new value of
tom on the bottom
you know send that out to all our nodes
they're going to come back
we have a majority at the bottom so we
can commit that and it'll push those out
down to the
the followers so the functioning cluster
at the bottom
has the new value of tom and then we
still have this
uncommitted entry of bob on the top once
the partition goes away
it's going to send out that heartbeat
and then what's going to happen first
is that the top candidate over there or
the leader is going to see that there's
a new term a new leader and a new term
so it's going to step down and become a
follower of term two that other follower
and turn one is going to flip over to
turn two and the next step we have after
that is that it's going to roll back any
uncommitted entries
so that you know the world's never seen
outside of that log
but the bob entry so everything's been
sally the whole time
so it's gonna roll back but roll back
that bob entry and then replicate any
entries
that the new leader has so it's tom so
now everybody's tom
okay okay i've got some questions uh
rich
so uh
how will the new later ever get tom from
a client
uh i mean you have to you'll have to
persist the actual current leader
within each of the the follower nodes or
have some system of keeping track of
that
as well um you can store it inside the
the servers and the nodes themselves to
pass it along and forward it if you
wanted to
but that's not necessarily part of the
protocol
how would you switch over from that
uh you have i mean there are some
different options you can have it just
stall on the the top ones if you wanted
to it's kind of
where it is right now i mean you can
have that um
the leader one time out eventually if it
can't connect to
a quorum uh there are some options but
it's not specified in the protocol
itself
um but that actual as far as passing
along to figure out
going from a follower to a leader um
you can specify that you know in the you
can keep that state in the nodes
themselves
and then pass along messages or just
notify the client this is the new leader
and they go and redirect their message
there it's not specified in the protocol
itself but there's different options
is that what you're asking rich okay uh
yeah go ahead
um one of the notes say that the one on
the bottom right
there one across the last verse decides
that it's a candidate
but then the petition immediately goes
away
and some of these you know heartbeats
if you have a leader and a candidate if
you have a leader in a candidate
the leader will step down on the top
because it sees that there's a higher
election term that's been started
although if it has a set of log entries
that are
if it's more up to date and it's log
entries and the other candidates then
it'll eventually become the candidate
and then leader itself again does that
make sense
okay so i mean if you had uh let's go
back to bob and sally here
uh okay in this sense yeah so in this
situation here if we
cut out the partition um
you know the top two nodes will the
leader at the top leader one
is gonna see that there's a new term so
it's gonna actually step down
but when these candidates at the bottom
then try to become actually let's go
back one more
here okay so we'll see that there's a
term two
on the top and i'll step down but this
candidate down here
one other rule is that you can't become
candidates if there are other
nodes with high like a more complete log
so basically the entries in the log are
further what's that
well that's true but you can't actually
so you can't commit unless you have a
majority and you can't get enough votes
to become a leader if you have
unless you have a majority so assuming
that
um something so assuming the sally down
here is going to become a leader it has
to have a majority and
at least one of those nodes will have
the most complete log
because that most complete log has to be
in a majority of notes
does that make sense yes okay it's it's
there's a nuance there definitely it's
kind of confusing um
yeah uh okay so it seems like the
hardest
thing about this is deciding how many
nodes are in the cluster
does that mean that you like is wrapped
a good protocol
for telling the cluster that it has just
grown two new nodes
yeah there's there's a there's a
protocol for actually adding
nodes there's some complexity there i
didn't really want to get into it this
time because it's kind of a whole
talk itself where you actually can have
these kind of uh
different sets of membership we could
you know be swapping out two nodes for
two other nodes
in which case you can actually have two
disjoint majorities
and then you actually have to combine
the two um
two sets of uh memberships to get a full
like a majority so it's confusing but
yes there is a way to
switch over the cluster membership does
that make sense okay
uh yeah say you have a
asymmetric network partition there's one
node which can no longer receive any
messages but it can still send messages
okay
so it becomes a candidate with a new uh
a new
term but they can still send its
requests for votes out but you can't get
the
actual words back in oh it's just
one of those caused the previous leader
to step down
without ability to actually take on a
new leadership itself
um that's a good question
uh yeah i mean if you can't it does
really rely on that
request response the full thing so if if
you have it asymmetrical
um it's i mean it'll essentially be
a you know a partition at that point i
mean even if it is asymmetrical i mean
you'll probably get a
candidate that tries to become the new
leader who may not be able to become the
new leader depending on the
you know how it's split as far as if
there's a majority it can access both
ways
you basically need bi-directional
communication to be able to become
a candidate and leader or become a
leader so
you can't get that split it works the
same way i would believe
as a asynchronous partition
i assume uh back then can you please
repeat the questions oh yeah i will do
sorry about that he asked if a
an asynchronous network partition would
cause a different issue or would cause a
problem of
a a leader trying to communicate down to
followers but those followers can't
respond or vice versa
and then those become candidates and
they can send out votes but can't
receive them there's just some
complexity around
asynchronous partitions
uh yeah also what if there's multiple
partitions
and as a result no no node can get a
majority of votes
oh then you're screwed you're down i
mean it essentially
you still need the majority that's kind
of the issue that's
one liability you have with doing this
kind of system although you ensure that
you only have
one actual value um
kind of one true like leader and value
at a given time
yeah right um
yeah so the client will get a
notification i mean it really depends on
how your
library is implemented in go raft
clients will connect and they'll hold
that connection until that uh the
command that they want to whatever they
want to do
is completed and committed and they get
a response back if it gets rolled back
for some reason then they'll get a
response
saying that it was an error so it when
it actually tries to read the system
you'll never read bob from the system
you'll try to write it but it can it can
block the right if it rolls back
go ahead so what if um like the leader
commits bob
and then the leader becomes partitioned
from the network so they can't
send the sort of final commit message to
all followers
so yeah okay so sorry i'm not repeating
the questions back there so he's asking
what happens if
um the leader up here commits bob and
then
let's go back a little bit uh let's see
here
so let's say the leader actually goes
out and comes back uh if it actually
could commit bob it would have a
majority
and you'd have bob on the majority of
nodes so even though it's committed
on um on that leader right there
and then it gets split off in the rest
of the partition
those other nodes are still going to
have the most up-to-date um
log so that when they try to you know
form a uh
let's try to determine a candidate and a
new leader they're going to pick the
person with the the most recent log does
that make sense
so you're always ensured that you have
that in there
yeah exactly so it's not committed to
everyone else but it's
uh it will be at some point uh which
okay yeah
uh does that make sense
oh god
um
but the right middle note doesn't know
that it's okay message was received
and then
so when the so the question is uh it's
similar
the follower in the middle i'll just
walk over it's easier so if
bob is replicated over to this one and
this one and they come back and confirm
uh to the leader that it's you know it's
committed
and these three up here uh leader
follower follower all have bob
but follower over here on the middle
doesn't actually realize
that it's committed yet still
uncommitted and then
this cluster down here this little sub
cluster tries to elect new leader
to answer your question that node right
there is always going to have the most
up-to-date
in this little sub-cluster so it'll
become the new leader
it will become the candidate and then
new leader to guarantee and that's why
you kind of have these majorities
on the uh the log replication and on the
um
uh the voting as well because you always
ensure that that
log is at least in that sub-cluster that
can go into
a new leader yeah yeah that's
some subtlety um an orange maybe this is
a fundamental assumption i'm not getting
but uh you could only
commit a client can only commit data to
a leader
yes um it really depends if you want to
support phantom reads or not
um if you yeah i mean you definitely
have some danger if you want to read
from
the clients themselves um ultimately you
know you'll probably get
yeah i mean it can be dangerous if you
want to do that but yeah you should read
and write through the leader itself if
you want to ensure
one value at a time so you have
replication but you still your
throughput can be limited
in that sense uh yeah
but it seems even in this case
so bob is actually uncommitted so the
value it's a little subtle under the
leader is actually sally until that's
committed
so you always read sally bob is never
actually a real committed value
any other questions so his questions are
going to not repeat
he was saying that bob up here could be
read from the leader but it's
it's not yet committed so leader one up
there will always be sally until we
connect down to this new
uh leader of the cluster later
for one more note
if you have two more that crash on there
oh if you had an additional two
on this cluster um then the total size
would be seven and your
majority would be uh what was it for
uh if they don't recover then you're
gonna have to remove them from the
cluster
membership okay i'm gonna there's just a
couple more left
let me do some more questions here
okay so i should just go till
summer schedule is 11 20 it's the end
okay
i got three minutes so really really
quick a lot of
uh you have an issue where you have this
log and it's just unbounded so obviously
you're going to run out of disk space
at some point even on your your sand you
got out there
it's eventually going to fill up
although the bigger issue that you
actually have
is that your recovery time is going to
increase so as you add more log entries
if a node goes down has to come back up
and replay all those entries of all your
your insets to your database your
updates your deletes your
drop your customer table whole thing
it's going to have to do all that stuff
over again and it's going to take a
while to recover
so you don't want your your nose to
recover after an hour
uh so there's actually three strategies
mentioned in the like a supplemental
paper
uh you have one where it's leader
initiated and stored in the actual log
that gets replicated out
so what happens is you kind of have the
snapshot that gets sliced up
and little chunks get embedded within
the the log that goes out
and there's a start point a start marker
and marker
so as it goes out the those follower
nodes will
collect the snapshot rebuild it and then
replay all the entries since the start
marker
another one is it's stored uh oh it's
initiated by the actual rap library but
it's just a whole block of snapshot
that just gets sent out and then the
rest of the entries come after that
and then the one that's actually
implemented go raft is the actual
application
kind of initiates when it should
snapshot and it works the same way the
snapshot goes out and then entries
follow after that okay so there's really
quick but hopefully
that makes some sense so if you have any
questions uh i'm ben b
johnson on twitter i'm also ben b
johnson on github and pretty much
everywhere else on the web
and then bandit skylinelabs.com if you
have
longer questions and 140 characters
right there